you never know billy lord is now a
mother and it has
everyone shook on thursday billy took to
instagram to reveal her and fiance
austin rydell are now proud parents
she's going to kill it she's perfect for
it the 28 year old actress had not
previously shared that she was expecting
billy captioned this photo introducing
kingston
fisher lord rydell and are those star
wars pajamas
that's no moon billy's scream queen's
co-star jamie lee curtis commented on
the pic
wait what austin and billy have been
engaged since
june she wants to be on tv so this is
just for us
and then i'll okay
you're on tv billy comes from a
hollywood
dynasty her mother carrie fisher and
grandmother debbie reynolds
died within days of each other in late
2016.
carrie and billy were seen hitting the
red carpet together throughout her
childhood
and billy even later joined the family
business general
are you seeing this two more x-wings
down she co-starred alongside her mother
in the final installments of the
skywalker saga
the mother-daughter duo shared a sweet
story with e.t at the premiere of star
wars the force awakens
i can't waste this moment having both of
you guys up here together
no i can't even come on i'm wondering
how are you as i see you guys coming up
the red carpet mother and daughter i'm
thinking to myself what's your first
star wars memory and then bring it
to this moment here with your mom now
come in here the first star wars memory
for my memory was me
kicking and screaming because she was
begging me to watch it i was like four
years old
she put it on like a beggar they did not
hire me because i was a beggar she's a
beggar and she's born to run
anyway whatever so she begged me to
watch it i obliged i
sat down i was like four